did you see that thing with the I
briefly mentioned I like alluded to it
the dear person yeah the the person
identifies as a deer yeah I know about
this
yes well I'm worried I wanted to talk
about it but I don't know if I want to
talk about well we're not going to show
it and we're gonna be light on it
because um I'm fully prepared to get
banned you know what I could say this
though I was thinking about going on
Twitch and not anymore
no way I have zero interest in streaming
on Twitch and I mean leave me out yeah
they're asking me to stream games like
I've been thinking about it I I did
actually sign into - I got a twitch
account I was prepped and ready and then
this whole thing came out and I was like
this is the person who's moderating
twitch yeah like what
twitch is always in bed all gamers are
white supremacist what yup get out of
here that's here that's what the dear
person said yeah no because that just
telling the truth and like these creepy
videos where they're like moaning mm-hmm
it is it's crazy and and there's one
video where there's current a dear
person was eating what looks like an up
OTT or something okay it's just weird
you don't you know I think it is I'm
totally prepared to get to get banned
over this to talk about it oh I love it
go for it this person I believe it's
voyeurism okay they like that voice it's
it's like you get off on people watching
you buy their be humiliated or engaging
in certain activities okay so there are
people who have a fetish for humiliation
okay so you think about what this person
is doing I think it's like a fetish they
go on camera and they make weird noises
and they act completely in a messed-up
way because when I was looking at some
of the statements made because I think
The Daily Beast said his story about
this dear person okay they were into it
they were like I want to do these videos
it was something that I thought would be
embarrassing and available and I'm like
yeah they're into this they they get off
on this they like it's it's it's it's
not normal but to an extent I'm fine
with it
you know if people have this thing the
problem is this person seems to be this
is where we're gonna get banned I'm just
gonna say it
dive deep mentally ill completely yeah
you said yeah we've talked about this
before no but that's a banner bull
defense saying like this person is and
I'm not you said I think
no no doesn't matter many mattr like you
I don't care I'm gonna say it because
this needs to be said this is not meant
to be disrespectful toward this person
mm-hmm voyeurism I think is people are
into that stuff that's fine yeah the
issue is this is someone who is unwell
and going on camera being like people
need to be afraid of me and now we can
see that there are these buzzards say
that yeah there are these companies
here's what I think happens when people
live in reality like when you live in
the real and I are l real world right
when you walk into a job they're looking
for a candidate and you know mr.
Kriegler walks in and they say look at
this guy he looks like some you know
hippie dippie long-haired you know are
you a hippie okay well you can have the
job then and you walk in and you're like
hi my name is you know I'm Tim nice to
meet you I'm here for the moderator
position they say okay but when you live
on the Internet you craft this shell
over what you really are yeah yeah a
persona people don't see what you really
are okay and so this gives opportunity
for people who normally wouldn't be in
these positions who are mentally ill and
for in a variety of ways to now be in
positions of power yeah and then when
they go on camera it's devastating to
your company so like I've had a lot of
conversations about you know will we do
this show on Twitch and I got to keep
that very very very vague the answer
right now is an overwhelming and
resounding no absolutely not absolutely
not
definitely not so I don't know too much
by this person but I do know that
there's an infiltration of people on
trust in safety teams think about you
know if you guys haven't seen these
videos ah you know you you you can check
it out I'm not here to drag this person
I'm not gonna say their name and maybe
that's good enough not to get banned or
whatever to get a strike or something
but you can look the stuff up I'm pretty
sure there's other dear people out there
dear floor bows right anyway you could
look at what this person is doing and
then when you realize the kind of
personalities I'll put it that way are
moderating these websites you also have
to understand that it's these people who
go on Twitter and like this
that something like voice chat is unfair
yeah unfair to like marginalized peoples
and women or something right
and those rules get implemented because
one person who is developmentally
disabled you know gets gets gets power
it's crazy to me that twitch that Google
that Facebook are scared of this yeah I
don't get it what's what's the line man
like look I understand there's a fear of
like the fascist who says like you know
do away with the invalids like that's
horrifying we don't we don't do that we
care about people right we also don't
put people who are developmentally
disabled in positions of you know
intellectual jobs like there's a
difference between saying like I doubt I
doubt that person's getting paid for
their position
they're probably overjoyed to just have
some power like I got power job cuz
people the rumor is that that person got
fired like oh recently oh yeah there's a
rumor it's happened well I don't know as
if people are saying okay that this
person has been fired well so they
should be fired for the things that they
were saying it's ridiculous I mean you
should be scared of me I have the power
now should should somebody be fired for
saying stupid things on the internet if
you're off it if you're in a position
that you need to my that you're a
moderator of something like twitch which
is a it's huge twitch is huge that's
where most of the gaming streams happen
so yes I think so if you're gonna openly
admit that you're not gonna be fair and
you're clearly biased against most
people that aren't you then yeah you
should be fired that all gamers are
white supremacists yeah that's right it
was something that something like that I
don't I don't I most I think they think
they said most gamers are white
supremacist and and we're saying and
we're saying they because I genuinely
don't know anything about this person
other than they do other than they
identify as a dear that's true and look
these videos are weird so you know it's
funny because I remember the
conversations like various organizations
where it's like don't say the word
normal and so it's like how do you refer
to an average person average average I
guess well so you see the aviary Bowser
saying normal you can't say normal that
was offensive what does normal mean what
is normal you know yeah are you saying
I'm not normal average you are not
average right so we can protect
marginalized communities
I'll put it this way if somebody's in a
wheelchair we create a wheelchair ramp
yeah we don't give them a job you know
as like a professional runner or like a
hockey referee yeah yeah it's like makes
them or you know and and and even
outside of that in more general
understanding of biology I will never be
in the NBA
there was there was there was like maybe
a point zero zero zero zero zero one
percent chance of me in my life
following the right path to somehow make
it in the NBA
you got the leg muscles I do I can jump
really high
well I can jump very high but not like
Muggsy Bogues man that dude was like was
he five three it was amazing I
presumably still is I don't know think
about them but there's there's there's
there's biological reality you know if
you don't have legs you're not gonna be
a leg model so I think about this way
when we see these people moderating for
twitch other other companies it would be
like taking someone who has a clear
mental developmental disability yeah and
being like we're gonna put you in it's a
chess grandmaster like you as a chess
player and it's like but that doesn't
make sense like you wouldn't you
wouldn't get an architect who can't
architect you know mm-hmm and that's
what we end up getting now here's the
scariest thing to go back to this point
is or I guess we just asked why is
YouTube afraid of these people you know
why that's a good question why what is
the reason you know cuz it's such a
minority you know why they're the
Screamers yeah they're the ones that are
really loud Asst yeah man you know it
might be it might be that regular people
will just say I don't care I don't want
to fight you know yeah actually this
this this lines up this like this
general idea so the way I explained it
before is for all those of you who are
listening you probably know Sargon of
Akkad is the the thing that I love this
because it's the most absurd way to
frame it do you think Sargon of Akkad
will form a large group of liberalists
and march down a twitter HQ with
pitchforks demanding the you know they
get reinstate otherwise they're gonna
smash windows up the answer is no yeah
yeah Sargon like he's not gonna lead and
he kind of like violent anything he'll
come down without wit with a camera on a
microphone and ask you questions and
complain about his rights
Antti fill up with crowbars and Molotov
absolutely absolutely so these companies
know don't make aunt Eva angry they're
the ones who get violent they'll come
after you and so that's what they've
been the need to and then then then you
end up with a trans-species dear person
going on stream and saying people should
be afraid of me because they're all
white supremacist and stuff like that
and that's the moderation we get yeah I
am terrified I'm out you're out
that's it no twitch well and then you
see the UN it's it's also like it's
spreading but it's fake so it's a fake
disease it's kind of like how to explain
it so it's like I'm imagining the color
is slowly being drained from the room
like you're sitting in a room and in the
corner it's like you have all these
brilliant colors and then all sudden
like the colors everything turning black
and white and you're like that is
spreading it makes no sense or it's like
imagine like your room so it's turned
like you just like a splotch of weird
tie-dye colors that's growing and
growing and growing in your house what
the UN is saying here with these words
makes literally no sense like so the
UN's tweet saying you know don't say
landlord say owner that clearly is the
opposite of social justice to refer to
someone who owns property as your owner
regressing my owner just raised my rent
that clearly makes no sense yeah it
doesn't make any sense and so what do
you think would happen imagine this if
someone was on stream and that was the
rule they were enforcing from now on you
can't sail and you guys a owner you got
to go on stream and you can't say that
word you got refer someone is here as
your owner that's weird it's I'd say
it's like not a real thing yeah I guess
the easy way to put is there's no
structure to any of it yeah it's like
you ask any of these people what do you
want me to do and I'll say stop being a
bigot and you're like please explain
what that mean nope I just get to call
you a bigot and you should be afraid of
me is the easiest way to sum up what
these people are and that's what that
person said yeah okay least you're
honest
saying the quiet part loud yeah that's
what they're thinking yeah you should be
afraid of me it's like I I can only
imagine somebody who's got a
developmental disability who thinks
they're a dear didn't fit in and is
upset and now wants to flex that power
against other people that's exactly what
it or some kind of power against other
people yeah and then they get on line
and they start banning people and then
these companies say but we're not
believed at all there's no bias
yeah twitches done man like I you know
they've already add a lot of problems
with popular females who break the rules
in such obvious ways yeah like there was
one video and I'll be very vague on this
but the the assertion was that this
woman did a nip slip Lunas an accident
oopsie sure oh no I was trying to take
something off then my you know don't ban
me please get away with it and then
there was like one there's one big thing
one of the reasons why I'm very averse
to twitch is there was apparently what
something happened where there was like
it was this like gamers versus thoughts
war okay when when when twitch were
started was both up by the gamer
community people who are like we're
gonna stream games and we're gonna you
know fun yeah and then a bunch of you
know like hot chicks realized they could
yeah thoughts they could do this thing
where I think that that might be been
able to to be honest but they did this
thing where they were like you can sit
in a chair leaning back with your legs
spread and like then lean for into the
camera so you can see cleavage and they
would get money yeah and so this started
breeding this and twitch leaned into it
like hey we're making loot you know you
know and the gamers got mad about it and
so apparently this one guy I don't REM
BER a whole lot of the story made a
video calling this out and he got banned
from twitch Wow and the thing the women
he was calling out they were breaking
the rules didn't get banned seems fair
yep twitches its Amazon now though but
man word man things are bad yeah maybe
Spotify will be better
I have vets that sounds pretty good I'm
pretty excited to see what Spotify is
doing but I don't I'd be surprised if
they have an open upload for videos but
if they did I'd totally sign up right
now it's uploading right yeah thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next episode
you